when i say tech industry you probably
think silicon valley but in ethiopia's
shiba valley there's a young tech
entrepreneur with a vision that's truly
global
i think currently the role of women in
tech is very little and in order to
inspire more young girls to join this
industry i think it's very important to
introduce role models and success
stories
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is beta liam desai and i am a
pioneer in tech education in ethiopia
betty lam desi is perhaps the youngest
pioneer in ethiopia's fast emerging tech
scene otherwise known as sheba valley
at only 20 years old she already has six
software programs copyrighted in her
name
and boy has she been busy
it all started when i was nine years old
and my father owned an electronic shop
so through that i was exposed to
computers and new technologies i was
able to learn how to build the website
how to code on html and such so that's
how i first started coding
those coding skills helped her to solve
the problems she saw around her for
example some schools in ethiopia don't
have access to science equipment so
betty lam developed software for a
virtual lab teaching students how to do
science experiments without any
equipment bringing science to more
students in more places she saw the
power of teaching others so she started
an initiative to do just that i cook
anyone can code focuses on teaching
young children from age 8 to 18 on the
basics of coding and robotics it's with
the idea of actually teaching children
the basic skills of problem solving
analytical thinking and such so that
they are ready for the skills that are
needed in the 21st century
bethlehem also works with young
scientists and innovators from all over
the country helping them showcase their
inventions
from football playing robots to racing
simulators these young people hope to
one day follow in the footsteps of this
african pioneer i feel very happy
because it's not only inspiring them but
it also inspires me to do more so that's
my motivation to continue seeing what
they're able to do and what they're able
to achieve through this program so i
think it's very necessary that i inspire
others so that it will help me grow and
innovate more
[Music]
you